in the figure above the seven small
circles which have equal radii and the
large circle are tangent at the
indicated points if the area of the
large circle is 36 PI so the area of the
whole thing right over here is 36 PI
what is the area of one of the small
circles so let's think about how we
could do this if we know the area of the
large circle we could figure out the
radius of the large circle if we know
the radius of the large circle we should
be able to figure out the radius of one
of these smaller circles so let's do
that so we know that area is equal to PI
R squared and so the Lark the area of
the larger circle is 36 PI so we know
that 36 pi is equal to PI R squared we
could divide both sides by PI divide
both sides by PI and we're left with the
radius of the larger circle I'll swap
the two sides the radius of the larger
circle squared is equal to 36 now if you
were just solving an equation R squared
is equal to 36 you would get that r is
equal to plus or minus 6 but we're
talking about a length here so we only
want to think about the principal root
of thirty-six so we get the radius of
the larger circle is 6 or another way to
think about it is the diameter of the
larger circle is going to be 12 diameter
is twice the radius so if we were to
start at this point right over here and
go all the way across go all the way
across that whole distance right there
is 12 so this distance right over here
the diameter of the larger circle is 12
now the diameter of the larger circle is
12 what is going to be the diameter of
one of the smaller circles and they all
have the same diameter well three of the
diameters of a smaller circle are equal
to the diameter of the larger circle so
each of these smaller circles are going
to have one-third the diameter of the
larger one so they're each going to have
a diameter of four well if they each
have a diameter of four that means that
they each have a radius of 2 so this
distance right over here this distance
right over here is too so now what is
the area of one of the small circles
well the area is going to
be pi times its radius squared so pi
times 2 squared which is equal to PI
times 4 or 4 pi so the area of one of
the smaller circles is or where e one of
the small circles is 4pi